et l'invité de tir croisé ce soir c'est
françois bayrou le patron du modem
bonsoir monsieur bayrou bonsoir merci
d'être sur notre antenne ce soir chaque
partie évidemment tire les leçons des
départementales qui ont vu la large
victoire de l'ump et de l'udf
ce matin nicolas sarkozy devant les
députés ump assuré que les électeurs à
travers leur vote lui demander une
opposition frontale
évidemment on veut face au gouvernement
il ajoute et ça c'est un message pour
vous monsieur bayrou on est avec nous ou
contre nous c'est trop simple de
braconner on ne peut pas avoir la clarté
avec le fn et la combinazione avec le
modèle vous savez ce que ça veut dire ce
mot italien monsieur bayrou en tout cas
j'ai lu j'élis normal que nicolas
sarkozy racontait alors hein c'est vrai
que c'est un nouveau titre de de gloire
d'être élevé au rang d'objets si on de
nicolas sarkozy puisque toutes ses
meetings toutes ces réunions il ya
forcément un passage obligé et de ce
point de vue là sur vos jeux
ça donne à sourire et c'est rigolo alors
intéressant mais il ya un truc précis
estime que dans le jura dimanche le
député ump damien meslot a été battu par
une alliance modem ps que c'est vrai
vous avez mené pour voir alors ceci est
absolument faux est d'abord on va
rectifier une eau de choses le député
ump damien meslot
le président de la république devrait
savoir que belfort ça n'est pas dans le
jura le président sort mais l'ancien
président de la république le président
de la république a été nicolas sarkozy
devrait savoir que belfort c'est pas
dans le jura c'est dans le territoire de
belfort
ça c'est une première chose deuxièmement
il y avait au 1er tour sept candidatures
dont un socialiste dont un front
national est en effet le protégé de
nicolas sarkozy sarkozy monsieur meslot
s'est retrouvé au deuxième tour contre
un de mes amis qui s'appelle christophe
grudler et qu'il a battu au 2e tour et
ça n'est en rien un accord
partisan de quelque nature que ce soit
c'est que les électeurs ont choisi que
christophe grudler modem c'était mieux
pour représenter leur canton que
monsieur meslot ump
mais ce qu'est ce que vous voulez que je
dise le le choix que nicolas sarkozy
laisse c'est qu'il faudrait que les
électeurs qui ne votent pas nicolas
sarkozy se voir retirer leur carte
d'électeur
après ça et de ce point de vue là centre
à vous de gagner toujours par un an je
n'ai absolument aucune notion de rancune
je pense simplement je pense pas depuis
maintenant je pense depuis des années
j'ai même écrit un livre sur ce sujet je
pense que nicolas sarkozy chaque fois
qu'il choisit d'être dans l'agressivité
chaque fois qu'ils ont choisi de dresser
les gens les uns contre les autres de
faire de la france le champ clos de
querelles partisanes
je crois que il choisit une voie qui
n'est pas la voie que la situation de la
france exige et je suis au contraire de
ceux qui pensent que c'est beaucoup
mieux pour le pays que de voir des
attitudes qu'ils soient des attitudes
qui permettent de rassembler qui
permettent de faire que des courants
politiques qui ont été différents et
même opposés par le passé puisse
travailler ensemble au redressement de
notre pays pourtant ce qu'il a réussi
avec l'alliance avec le dé monsieur
bayrou c'est indéniable c'est classique
n'est ce pas il ya toujours eu une
alliance qui fasse que le parti ce que
je crois que nicolas sarkozy utiliser
une métaphore disait la grosse boîte ir
la petite
vous vous souvenez de cette phrase qui
était qu'ils étaient
non une phrase de de physique pisé ça
moi je pense que ça c'est absolument
classique mais je ne pense pas que la
vie politique française puisse résumer à
la question de savoir si c'est hollande
sarkozy le pen en tout cas là il ya une
année avec jean christophe lagarde des
porte ses fruits phase prolongée aux
régionales s'il ya des abus vous savez
qu'ils sont en location et vous n'avez
pas marre d'être le vilain petit canard
du sang mais je peux tu être vous vous
trompez sur la définition du centre le
centre ça n'est pas une succursale de
l'ump il ya des gens qui pensent que le
centre est forcément dans cette
comment dirais-je soumission c'est la
garde non non j'essaie de dire des
choses qui soit agressive pour personne
mais ma conception à moi du centre c'est
que c'est un centre qui est liban
indépendant qui impose un style
politique différent et ce style
politique
il porte ses fruits car contrairement à
ce que vous dites c'était pas du tout
une alliance exclusive ump unis
c'était une alliance dans la plupart des
départements ump udi modem est par
exemple dans les pyrénées atlantiques le
département que je représente dont je
suis maire du chef lieu dans les
pyrénées atlantiques
ce qui a permis le renversement du
département vous aura pas échappé que la
carte politique de la france c'est tout
le sud-ouest en rose sauf un département
qui est le département des pyrénées
atlantiques pourquoi parce que nous
avons proposé est imposé et convaincu
les électeurs avec un style politique
est une pratique politique différente
encore un mot assez sa droite
non mais vous voyez bien à quel point
c'est important parce que croire que la
situation de la france sera réglé en
remettant l'ump à la place du ps comme
on a 1000 ps à la place de l'ump pour
moi je n'en crois pas un mot
je pense que la situation du pays exige
je exil orale qu'on met une proposition
politique nouvelle
peut-être une majorité nouvelle manière
différente de voir les choses dans
l'avenir pas la grande coalition a
simplement la restauration de ce qui
était aux responsabilités avant et qu'on
remettra aux responsabilités après et je
suis absolument persuadé qu'il y a des
millions de français qui ne croient pas
que le vote de dimanche soit autre chose
qu'un vote sanction il voté contre la
gauche au pouvoir et pour des raisons
précises mais ils n'ont pas pour autant
donner leur adhésion à l'ump un mot de
l'année d'après en 2016 de la droite
après nicolas sarkozy et les modalités
seront connues dans les tout prochains
jours
jean christophe lagarde estime qu une
première n'aurait pas de sens sans la
participation du modem et sans la vôtre
est ce que vous répondez à monsieur la
gare vous voyez c'est c'est bien d'être
le sujet des conversations n'ont aucune
candidature prévue de votre part est
l'enjeu
si si on peut au delà du sourire essayez
de dire les choses comme elles sont ma
réticence ou ma réserve à l'égard d'une
primaire elle vient de ce que la
primaire elle donne toujours la prime
aux plus dures au plus mobilisés de
chaque camp et que ce ce noyau dur des
camps ils commandent d'habitude la
victoire de la primaire on connaît ça
partout il ya des primaires les
républicains américains les démocrates
américains c'est souvent que ça se passe
comme ça et pour moi je pense que la
france a moins besoin de noyau dur
aujourd'hui que de gens qui ont une
volonté du courage de l'autorité et qui
soit capable de créer un soutien large
de l'opinion et pas seulement un soutien
de caen si vous n'avez qu'un soutien de
caen chaque fois qu'il ya une alternance
ou vous retrouver
comme on se retrouve aujourd'hui avec
une gauche rapetisser et une droite
qu'il était si fière gauche dans tous
ses états en fait aujourd'hui les uns à
matignon de manuel valls est ce que le
premier ministre a failli dans sa tâche
il affirme maintenir le cap de ses
réformes reste il reste évidemment à son
poste après la claque électorale de
dimanche qu'elle lisibilité pour les
français
bayrou oui c'est une c'est une question
importante mais tout cela les
soubresauts à gauche les affrontements à
gauche le le fait qu'il y ait des
désarrois dans le camp de la majorité
tout cela s'explique pour par une seule
raison c'est que ils sont pas d'accord
sur le fond c'est qu'il y à deux lignes
politiques de vision de l'avenir du pays
l'une quitte une vision de rupture et
l'autre qui est une vision d'adaptation
et la vision de rupture avec le système
économique dans lequel nous vivons c'est
à peu près la moitié de la gauche et la
vision d'adaptation au système
économique c'est à peu près la moitié de
la gauche etc inconciliables alors
françois hollande a beau faire des
acrobaties il est expert en acrobaties
de ce point de vue là pour essayer de
concilier l'inconciliable
moi je pense que l'échec des trois
années qui viennent vivre c'est que
cette question n'a pas été tranchée dès
le début comme elles auraient dû l'être
manuel valls se fait à peu près la même
analyse que que vous un d'une grande
coalition d'une majorité qu'il faudrait
ouvrir et le tend la main aux vins avec
les difficultés qu'ils rencontrent s'il
tendait la main si vous tendez la main
en disant voilà venez le gouvernement
les partis de gouvernement vont s'en est
ouverte est ce que cette coalition la
vous conviendrait sur la base d'un
programme très clair aucune hésitation à
vous répondre ça n'est absolument pas en
question me ni deux
imaginables pourquoi parce que il ne
pourra y avoir de changement de base peu
du politique changement que je crois
nécessaire
le jour où on voudra une politique
réformiste courageuse et qui soit juste
en même temps alors il faut une majorité
large cette majorité large ne pourra pas
être tenu tant qu'on n'aura pas changer
une règle électorale absurde injuste et
qui oblige au clivage la proportionnelle
est donc mal à régler toral européenne
puisque c'est la règle électorale de
tous les pays européens continentaux
sont sans aucune exception sauf nous et
l'allemagne et pas mal gouvernés et les
autres pays ne sont pas mal les pays
scandinaves ne sont pas mal gouverné
avec une autre règle rita faire entrer
des dizaines mais madame ils
représentent des français et des siens
je me suis toujours opposée à leur idée
est peut-être encore davantage à leurs
obsessions et ce sont des français comme
vous et comme moi et comme monsieur
valls et comme monsieur sarkozy ils ont
le même droit électoral
ils ont la même carte de vote dans la
roche
de quel droit des gens qui sont
supérieures ou qui se croient tél
peuvent-ils dire mesdames et messieurs
vous avez un vote qui ne nous convient
pas donc vous ne serez pas présenté de
quel droit
de quelle légitimité qui sont ceux qui
ont voulu cette cette injustice là moi
je dis bah qui sont-ils le ceux qui ont
bâti un système qui avec le temps est
devenu un système de monopole de pouvoir
pour deux formations politiques selon et
donc pour moi il n'y a aucune légitimité
à dire cela et s'il ya des français qui
votent pour ces formations politiques
que je combats vous rappelle sans sans
avoir jamais varié et bien il faut qu'il
soit représenté et ça obligera peut-être
les autres à réfléchir à ce qui les
rapproche et à avoir une attitude qui
change pour les français qu'ils ne
soient plus digne que les affrontements
complètement artificielle et stérile de
ces gens qui s'injurient d'un bout à
l'autre de l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
en prétendant que c'est la faute des
autres
le chômage ou le déficit la réalité
c'est effectivement le transporteur
auraient globalement il ya un peu de
1500 salariés liquidation prononcée
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il aurait fallu
faire pour éviter ce drame qui leur vie
d'entreprise l'entreprise il y a deux
ordres de cause possible la première
cause c'est des causes de gestion d'une
entreprise
mais la deuxième cause c'est qu'il y ait
un déséquilibre entre ses activités
économiques en france et des activités
économiques de concurrents qui nous
entoure tant qu'on n'aura pas un projet
de rapprochement des législations
sociales qui fasse que les charges
soient les mêmes chez nous et chez nos
principaux voisins et que on aura comme
on l'a fait pour l'euro pour les
déficits qu'on ait un projet de
rapprochement de rapprochement des
législations sociales et des charges
sociales
tant qu'on fera pas ça on mettra un
certain nombre d'entreprises dans un
certain nombre de secteurs dans une très
grande difficulté de sorte que on est
obligé de rechercher l'harmonisation
sociale hommes entre eux comme on a
recherché l'harmonisation budgétaire et
comment devra rechercher l'harmonisation
fiscale
7 cette manière de de déséquilibrer les
choses
elle est anti françaises et
anti-européenne croyez pas la reprise
économique tant espérée par manuel valls
et françois hollande
non mais j'entends dire que ça y est
convié mais ça fait dix ans que
j'entends dire que ça y est on y est et
pour moi en tout cas je ne vois pas
d'éléments probants qu'ici que
la reprise est là et pour une raison que
je vais examiner avec vous qui est très
simple qui est que les planètes comme
disent les gouvernants quand les
éléments de la situation devienne plus
favorables ce qui en profitent c'est
ceux qui sont le plus près et ce sont
nos concurrents qui sont plus prêts que
nous le sommes plus actifs ou réactifs
que nous ne le sommes qui risque d'en
profiter et singulièrement nos
concurrents allemands par exemple qui
comme vous savez on fait cette année
près de 250 milliards d'excédents de
leur commerce extérieur quand nous
faisions 60 milliards de déficit
merci beaucoup françois bayrou d'être
venus ce soir sur i télé dans un instant
la météo et le journal serait à tout de
suite